a lot I don't know how much you know
about her but the Pick Me label oh yeah
so do you I'm guessing you get called
you know a woman hate or a pick me what
do you think about that oh well okay
first of all I was like what the hell is
a pick me and so then there it's like
basically you say things so men will
pick you yeah but I'm like I just say my
thoughts I clearly am not that filtered
you know what I mean like I clearly like
sometimes I should say less I
I saw you yesterday on the show and
you're like the whales came for me and
I'm like she's talking about fat people
yeah yeah yeah sometimes my manager's
like yeah yeah so first of all second of
all I'm like pygmy that's the insult
that you want to get married yeah I want
to get married like but don't you think
it's interesting that they label like
men can't criticize modern women because
they'll be labeled misogynists women
can't criticize modern women because
they'll be labeled a pick me so nobody
can criticize these women isn't that
convenient yeah and then they'll go to
the personal attacks like well why
aren't you why are you single and I'm
like that's what I'm saying true or is
it not true I'll be like Rebecca seven
abortions is a lot I don't know what
you're doing I met a girl had seven her
name's not actually Rebecca seven
abortions wow seven and I'm like that's
a lot that is madness and it's like is
that true or is it untrue or should we
encourage it to get to ten should we
encourage it to get to ten
yeah what do you think is the biggest
mistake that young girls are making
today
oh um well I mean I think I think your
virginity is very valuable and I feel
like it's like giving giving that to
some like just a way you know yeah
that's what I would say yeah and just
like promiscuity I would say now you
have one thing that's interesting about
you is you're very open about your
family like you always will reference
your dad and you'll say on the show like
my dad's in the one percent the top do
you get heat for that do people say oh
to write you off as privilege from the
start or yeah that's why I don't try to
hide it because it's like they're gonna
find out anyway you know no um my dad is
like the best person my dad is so nice
like literally he helps everyone and
he's so like I'll call him crying and
he's like stop it
so is he that masculine guy that you're
like it does does your relationship with
your dad or like your family Dynamic did
that inform how you feel about male
female Dynamics in any way or does that
play a role
yeah of course of course it does like
thinking because I would say my dad is
like not red pill like he doesn't know
what the hell I mean he's been a little
bit red pill just because because of the
contest no because of me I'll be like
Dad you won't believe the stat I found
out today I love it I love it but yeah I
mean I really appreciated being grown up
with like two parents in the home and
especially the more I talk to people
that did it because it's like really sad
when I hear about their holidays and
stuff like there's so many people that
my mom would kill me if I didn't go home
for Christmas and then like I'm in
England and there's like other athletes
and they're like I don't know we're not
doing anything for Christmas I'm like
you're not doing anything for Christmas
yeah my mom would would strangle me so
what do you want like if you were to
look at your life you know because the
other criticism that will come to you if
it hasn't already is like people will
say well sure she's talking about
traditional roles but here she is with
this successful YouTube channel and
she's an entrepreneur in her own right
and what do you say to people say oh my
gosh I thought it was gonna be a hobby
this took up fast and why why did he
think it blew up like that oh um
well I was posting more than everyone
else so and I I just I actually was
funny I got out of a relationship and I
was kind of sad so I was like I'm gonna
just make a show and then all this will
like distract me you know
um and then yeah I just started doing
the show I mean what do I say to that I
would say
um okay I'm looking so oh Pearl's
looking in the chat in case you're in
there we're gonna get to the chat in
just a second I think sometimes people
will be like oh why aren't you married
today tomorrow and I'm like look it I'm
learn I'm learning to cook I'm talking
to wives I'm doing the best that I can
you're doing the work I look at I'm like
I'm doing the best I can
um you know
um yeah that's that's all I can say
listen people get out of a relationship
and eat a lot of ice cream you start a
YouTube channel I think that's a good
thing you're making people think you
know all that stuff Delly you ready you
got some chat some of y'all went to the
club that's right so we all went to the
club no joke people went to the club and
drank too much Tyrone I made a YouTube
channel there you go and she's helping
you she's helping you all right let's
get some questions from the chat Delhi
ready yeah yeah yeah
um Paulo just sent twenty dollars said
Jed you're amazing oh thank you
uh Samuel said Jed you're amazing and
I'm a big fan of only disagree with
Tate's view about having multiple kids
from multiple women oh that's
interesting do you have an opinion about
that Pearl oh that triggered me too when
I first heard it
um
see it's hard okay sometimes I look at
things as a society perspective right
and when you think about it from a
society perspective that's always
happened so who am I to say come in and
say well do it my way because I liked it
with my parents so
um I wouldn't prefer it you know I doubt
that'd be your first choice either
wouldn't be who I'd pick but I think
it's silly to say that quality woman
wouldn't do that because they have for
all of history so yeah it depends on the
guide depends on the situation I would
say like people have to choose the
relationship they want but I also talk
from a societal perspective about
monogamy and the reason I I don't tell
people what to do but the reason I
believe in monogamy is just I feel like
it's a it's a Bedrock of society like
it's something that stabilizes family
and that's good for community and good
for country and all that stuff but you
know do what you want I I agree with you
I was just thinking I was like you know
I'll give the billionaires multiple
lives
we need those genes replicated
so I'll give I'll give them you know
maybe 100 millionaires billionaires
pearls Pearl's World pearls which is
satire
I was trying to make it what else you
got jelly
um another comment from Steven said
everyone should hit the vice comment
thread asking for the unedited version
oh yeah please yeah do it they'd never
show that no they would never do it then
uh Pat Steadman said see how Tate was
edited by Pierce Morgan years ago how
roosh was edited after appearing on Dr
Oz should she know better than to go on
Vice
yeah I just I just was going to do it
anyway I was like you can't yeah I still
felt like this is in my prayer I still
felt like I came out more sane than
those crazies even let me ask you
however much they edited it cameras off
did you did you how did you did you get
along with those women because they
looked pissed and actually oh wait Eli
tweeted did you see it did you see what
I tweeted back tweeted I don't know if
you have that in the copy I saw it no I
didn't see the feedback but this is what
Eli this is a I keep saying it because
I'm going to it's a biological man trans
woman says ready to get heated I joined
advise news words of eight panel on
feminism it's not helpful to platform
fascists like Vice did this talking
about you about a fashion it's a harsh
accusation but I figured the least I
could do is prevent the anti-feminism
spreading even more disinformation
there's that word they love oh somebody
they disagree with that hurt their
feelings disinformation what did you
Tweet back I didn't say oh I tweeted
aren't you a predator or am I tripping
no no I'm gonna be honest he could be he
could I'm just saying if you're gonna
call me a fascist yeah I'm gonna I'm
gonna point out that so how was it when
the cameras weren't rolling with Eli and
crew well before they separated the
conservatives and the lips so like they
put us in different rooms and it was
very like they were kind of they had
people in there and they're like don't
talk about polit like don't talk about
the panel stuff which I understand I do
that too sometimes yeah before shows
I'll be like don't talk about the topic
ah because you want to get it on camera
so I I respect that I understand that
um
then we do the panel which is super long
oh my gosh I was so hot too you know how
like sometimes it gets like hot in these
it's hot in here yeah yeah UK there's no
AC yeah that's why you see people
sweating on the show sometimes they just
don't have it there I don't know
but but they um basically I forgot where
I was going oh then after it was so
awkward because it was like we both went
in our groups and we're just talking
[__] about the others at like lunch or
whatever but no I did not get along with
them especially a lady as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible